The Owl and the Pussycat went to sea in a beautiful pea-green boat.
They took some honey and plenty of money, wrapped in a five-dollar note.
The Owl looked up at the stars above.
He sang with a small guitar.
Oh, lovely Kitty, oh Kitty, my love.
What a beautiful Kitty you are. You are. You are.
What a beautiful Kitty you are.
Kitty said to the Owl.
You're such a nice fowl.
And how wonderfully sweet you sing.
Then the lovely Kitty said.
I think we should wed.
But what shall we do for a ring.
They then sailed away for a year and a day to the land where the Pong tree grows.
And there in the wood a piggy wig stood.
She had a ring at the end of her nose, her nose, her nose.
She had a ring at the end of her nose.
Then they asked the fat pig.
Will you trade the ring for a wig?
Said the fat piggy.